prediction is very difficult especially
if it's about the future and even more
so if it's about the future of
JavaScript as app developers will be
spending the rest of our lives in the
future of JavaScript so in today's video
we'll look at new features coming to the
language the current state of front-end
frameworks and new features they're
releasing as well as disruptive trends
that could change everything in 2020 and
if you're here because you paid
JavaScript make sure to stay tuned until
the end because we'll look at a few
tools that you can use to build web apps
without JavaScript the future of
JavaScript isn't what it used to be make
sure to LIKE and subscribe and let me
know what you think about javascript in
the comments below one lucky comment
will win this one of a kind t-shirt
let's start things off by taking a look
at some of the newest features coming to
a javascript near you in 2020 and if you
don't already know how new features make
their way into the language make sure to
check out my history of JavaScript video
it explains the purpose of Technical
Committee 39 and how proposals make
their way into the language as actual
features you can see all the proposals
on github there are currently eight
finished proposals slated to be
published in 2020 but many of them have
already been shipped to the browser no
js' in typescript so you can start using
them today let's take a look at a few of
the big ones and see why they're awesome
and when you would want to use them
dynamic imports a function that allows
you to lazily import a module at runtime
in other words your imports no longer
have to be static at the top of the file
you can load modules asynchronously from
anywhere in your code this means you can
delay the loading of non-essential
dependencies in your application to
improve performance notice in this code
snippet how we're awaiting the loading
of a module as a promise when the user
clicks a button next we have optional
chaining which is the most popular new
feature according to my extremely
limited Twitter poll we call it the
Elvis operator for obvious reasons if
you've ever used angular it should look
very familiar to you it makes it
possible to call a deeply nested object
property without throwing an error if
its parent property is undefined if
you've ever used the low - git function
this is a good replacement for it it's
extremely useful if you're working with
an API or database that returns a bunch
of deeply nested
objects and you don't want your app to
break it run time if intermediate
properties on those objects are
undefined next we have a similar looking
new feature called the no leash coalesce
Kian operator in many cases you might
want to set a default value for a
property when it's undefined you can
already do that in JavaScript using a
logical or
operator but it can be problematic if
the defined value is a zero or an empty
string because JavaScript will coerce
those values to false Eve it's super
annoying because then you have to do
runtime type checking in your code in
2020 no more the double question mark is
false e only if it's null or undefined
so the end result is more predictable
code when setting default values
javascript is also getting a new
primitive data type a big int it can
represent numbers beyond JavaScript
smack safe integer value which is
limited to 64 bits you can create a big
aunt by adding an end to a regular
integer or you can use the big in
constructor to make numbers that are
completely massive but to be honest it
probably won't be needed by most
developers unless you're doing extremely
precise time stamps or geometric
calculations but it is a JavaScript
primitive so you should definitely know
about it so that gives you a preview of
things coming to JavaScript but make
sure to check out all the finished
proposals on github let's switch gears
to one of the biggest disruptions in the
JavaScript world typescript it first
appeared on the 2016 Stack Overflow
survey being used by less than half of
1% of developers fast forward three
years it's now a top ten language used
by more than 20% of developers it's one
of those rare technologies in the Jas
world that seems to be well loved by
both front-end and back-end developers
and across frameworks now you might have
watched my prediction video last year my
first prediction was that 2019 would be
the year of web components at this point
I'd have to say that mostly has not been
the case they did see more adoption in
2019 but not in any big spectacular way
more importantly they saw a lot of
criticism and a lot of pushback but
there are some really good tools out
there dedicated to building web
components like stencil and lit element
which is another Google sponsored
project that has been gaining a lot of
steam lately now let's talk about some
front-end frameworks starting with the
big underdog of 2019 spell it's been
around for a few years but in April 2019
3 was released it generated a ton of
excitement because it's put together
into a very elegant easy to learn
package and it's highly performant with
no runtime dependencies its npm
downloads have roughly tripled over the
last year and it's a great place to take
refuge from the status quo speaking of
which let's take a look at react angular
in view in terms of adoption react is by
far the dominant force with more than
twice as many downloads
as angular and view combined but
downloads are just one piece of data in
a bigger picture let's also take a look
at jobs on Stack Overflow
we've got 850 openings for react 388 for
angular and 156 for view so we have a
similar distribution with react as the
clear leader last year the big new
feature in react was hooks today we have
another big experimental feature in
react concurrent mode it allows the
framework to handle multiple state
updates at the same time and it opens
the door for a new built in react
component called suspense suspense will
wait for asynchronous activity to finish
and it's children such as an API call to
a cloud database or better yet using the
new dynamic imports feature to lazy load
a react component at runtime that means
you can handle loading states
declaratively and you don't need to
manually toggle some kind of boolean
value in your code now moving on to the
angular world the big new update is ivy
it's enabled by default in angular 9 and
it's an entirely new compiler for
angular but what's more exciting to me
is that someone finally decided to build
a static site generator for angular by
coincidence they're expected to release
an alpha version of it today so we can
see how it compares to Gatsby view press
and so on moving on to the view world a
big new feature is the composition API
it's a set of tools aimed at providing
better code reusability in complex view
applications it does that by taking some
of views' core capabilities like
reactive State and exposing them as
functions these smaller pieces can then
be used to compose more complex
components and they're much easier to
strongly type with typescript so
frameworks are cool on all but the web
platform itself has some new features
that fundamentally extend at the types
of applications that you can build on
the web a huge one is the web
authentication API or web authenticate
via hardware-based authenticators and
that means your web app can do things
like biometric off and another one to
keep an eye on is the native file system
API which can give your web application
access to the user's local files
something that web developers have
wanted since the beginning of time it's
currently available in Chrome with a
flag but other than that it's not
supported another small but awesome
feature is the new loading attribute for
images and iframes there's a million
different lazy loading JavaScript
libraries out there but now it's built
into the browser natively with a simple
HTML attribute
now speaking of browsers there's a
disruptive new browser out there called
brave I started using it a few weeks ago
and now I use it for almost 90 percent
of my browsing both on mobile and
desktop the CEO of the company is none
other than Brendan Eich the creator of
JavaScript the browser feels almost just
like Chrome and you can install all the
Chrome extensions that you know and love
but it feels faster because it's
blocking ads and trackers by default
JavaScript of course is not just for the
browser we also have no js' the most
exciting new feature a node has to be
worker threads one of the biggest
limitations of JavaScript that people
like to point out is that it's single
threaded that means you can't have two
single processes running at the same
time in 2020 that's no longer an issue
because we now have the worker threads
module and it opens the door to use
threads to execute JavaScript in
parallel another awesome feature that
shipped a node is support for es modules
in node 13 you can use import and export
statements instead of require one of the
fastest-growing back-end tools for node
is nest Jas
it takes advantage of typescript to
build server-side applications that
scale and that are very developer
friendly nest Jas can also help you
integrate another disruptive technology
graph QL this is a trend that has been
ongoing for a couple years now but graph
QL is just continuing to grow and grow
when it comes to deploying your back-end
you have a lot of different options
which you can see in my cloud computing
20/20 video but as it turns out many web
applications in today's world don't need
to build their own back-end at all it
can be far more productive to use
something like AWS amplifier firebase
both of which are continuing to grow as
well these tools provide everything you
need to grow and scale a mobile
application allowing your team to
focused almost entirely on building an
awesome front-end user experience but
javascript isn't just for browsers and
servers it's also for mobile
applications the big one of course is
react native and we also have ionic and
native script they've all remained
pretty much flat over the last year in
terms of NPM downloads react native has
added some nice new improvements like
fast refresh and ionic now supports
react where they previously only
supported angular but all in all not too
much exciting to speak of in this space
and that gives us a perfect segue into
the JavaScript anti-heroes the emerging
technologies where you might place your
bets
other than javascript in june of 2019
Apple released Swift UI it provides a
way to build declarative you eyes
similar to how you would with react but
with the Swift programming language so
it promises to greatly improve the iOS
developer experience but again it's only
for iOS when it comes to building
cross-platform apps for iOS and Android
a big disruptive forces flutter it uses
the dart programming language which is
very similar syntactically to JavaScript
and in 2019 dart was the fastest growing
programming language and flutter of one
of the hottest open-source projects on
github and it also now supports the web
as a target in beta but in the long term
an even bigger disruption to the
JavaScript ecosystem is webassembly
just a few days ago web assembly became
an official fourth language on the web
alongside javascript HTML and CSS now I
don't want to come off as if web
assembly is going to replace javascript
in fact that's not the case at all it's
a complement to JavaScript allowing us
to build an even greater variety of
applications and more importantly better
quality applications as good as any
desktop app my favorite case study is
figma if we look closely at their
product we'll see they have a shell but
with react inside that shell we have a
high performance design tool powered by
web assembly in fact I used figma to
design the cover for this video
currently flaming is like C C++ and rust
can compile to blossom and it's starting
to emerge on even more languages like C
sharp Microsoft recently released a new
framework called blazer and partially
through the magic of web assembly it
allows you to build web applications
using C sharp HTML and CSS and in the
future I'd expect to see even more
languages that can elegantly inter off
with JavaScript we've covered a lot in
the last 10 minutes but that's just a
small sample of everything that's going
on in the massive JavaScript world we
have tools like Cypress that are
changing the way we test our
applications tools like Gatsby that
changed the way we build our JavaScript
apps and we have tools like X State
giving us new ways to think about state
management I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there thanks for watching and
remember to always bet on JavaScript
[Music]